네 오늘 명동에 대해서 좀 얘기를
해보도록 하겠습니다 어 명동 땅값이
여러분들 되게 궁금해하실 건데 명동
땅값은 최고가로 찍힌게 10억 전체가
다 10억이 아니라 한 평당
10억입니다
2017년도에 명동역 메인거리에 있는
건물인데 요게 대지가 한 31평 정도
됩니다요 건물인데 315억 매각이
됐습니다 그래서 대지 평당 10억 한
2천만 원 정도에 매각이 됐고 그리고
더 재밌는 사례는 지금은 있는 건데
땅 모양이 이거예요 되게 얇죠 거의
약간 빼빼로 느낌의 어 이런 땅이
있습니다 그래요 땅이 평이에요 몇
면지 하면 한 108평 정도 되는데
건물이 200억 평짜리 영동 메인에
있는 건물이 200억 원에
2018년도에 매각이 됐었고 대부분
다 이쪽 길에 있는 건물들은 한 6
70년도 때 건물들이 많아요
1971년도에 지금 건물인데 평짜리
땅을 200억 원의 매장이 됐습니다
그리고 지금 명동이 코로나 때 매우
안 좋았어요 거의 관광객이 한 거의
90% 이상 빠졌었고 그 기회를
틈타서
2021년도에 더 초입에 있는 요건
돼지가 55평 있니다이 건물요 건물을
330억 그러니까 대지 평당 6억 원
정도에 매입한 거예요 그래 같은 길에
있던 두 건의 사례는 대지 평당
10억에 매각이 됐는데 코로나 이후에
좀 급매로 나왔던이 건물을 33
30억 원에 매입했습니다 그래서
연면적이 무려 348명 정도 돼요 한
100평 정도 되는데 이건 거의 세
배죠 굉장히 좀 싸게 산 어 그런
사례라고 보시면 될 거 같아요 좀
그렇게 위기 때 투자를 해서 성공한
어 그런 사례라고 좀 보여지고 지금은
명동이 너무 좋아졌어요 관광객들도
너무 많아졌고 그래서 얼마 전 기사를
보니까 명동의 1m 월 임대료가
76만 원 그래서 세계에 한 6 9위
정도 된다 그러더라고요 여러분들
아셔야 될게 1제곱미터 가 한 평이
아니거든요 한 평은 한 3.3 미예
그래서 여기서 한 세배 정도 더
보시면 될 거 같아요 200만 원
초반 정도 그래서 내가 평을 쓴다
그러면 월 임대료가 2천만 원 초중반
정도 됩니다 그만큼 명동 임대료가
엄청난 거예요 평에 2천만 원이라고
생각해 보세요 지금 뉴욕 5번가에
있는 메인 메인 거리죠 메인 거리가
1제곱미터당 240만 원 정도
239만 원에서 3,3 거의 800만
원입니다 그래서 뉴욕 5번과 메인에
있는 매장 같은 경우에 한 평당 월
임대료가 한 800만 원 정도 됩니다
그래서 만약 10평 정도 쓴다 그러면
여기는 월세가 거의 한 8천만 원
정도 이렇게나 비싸다고요 밀라노도 어
제곱미터당 211만 원 홍콩이 한
178만 원 그다음에 런던이 한
174만 원 파리의 메인 거리가 한
134만 원 명동이 76만 원 명동
임대료가 또 상당히 높은데도 명동이
세계 9입니다 임대료 수준 그리고
여러분들 공시지가 발표할 때 아마
많이 기사 나갔던 건데 네이처 퍼블릭
있던이 건물이 우리나라에서 공시
지가가 제일 높은 어 그 건물입니다
매년 이제 뉴스에 나오는 건물입니다
동의이 거리가 제일 번화한 거리고
대부분의 사람들이 강남이 제일
비싸다고 생각을 하겠지만 우리나라에
제일 비싼 곳은 바로 동입니다 명동이
돼지다 거의 한 10억 정도 매각된
그런 사례가 있고 강남 대로변에도
최고가가 거의 6억 뭐 7억이 정도
수준인데 명동은 무려 10억에 어
매각된 그런 사례가 있습니다